يعقد الائتلاف الوطني لقوى الثوره
والمعارضه السوريه اجتماعا في القاهره
لاستكمال الهيكل السياسي للائتلاف وتسميه
رئيس حكومه مؤقته ياتي الاجتماع بعيد
انتخاب العميد سليم ادريس رئيسا للقياده
العسكريه الموحده للثوره السوريه
ام
نتوقف بعد الخبر لن نفسه من زاويتين ما هي
العقبات التي ظلت يعرقل استكمال الاطر
الانتقاليه للمعارضه السوريه كل هذا الوقت
وما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه هذه الاطر لتواكب
التقدم السريع الذي يحققه المقاتلون على
الارض
السلام عليكم
على وقع زخم ميداني اخذ في الارتفاع ومع
تقدم الثوار ب معاركهم الى داخل العاصمه
السوريه دمشق يجتمع قاده الائتلاف الوطني
لقوى الثوره والمعارضه السوريه في القاهره
في مسعى لاستكمال هيكله وتشكيل حكومه
انتقاليه تسد فراغا لطالما تحجز به
المجتمع الدولي حقا وباطلا لتبرير مواقفه
مما يجري في سوريا والتي جاءت اقل كثيرا
من تطلعات انصار الثوره
عن الجبهه السياسيه هذه المره يتحرك الملف
السوري نحو افق جديد الائتلاف الوطني لقوى
الثوره والمعارضه السوريه يعقد اجتماعا
طارئا في العاصمه المصريه القاهره ليختار
رئيس حكومه سوريه مؤقته وكان الائتلاف
الذي شكل هيئه تنفيذيه شهرا بعد ان راى
النور كان قد اقر اليه محدده بخصوص اختيار
رئيس الحكومه المؤقته يقضي بان يرشح كل
مكون من مكوناته اسما ليستقر التوافق على
ثلاثه اسماء ثم يقع اختيار احدها عن طريق
التصويت جاء اجتماع الدوحه في الحادي عشر
من تشرين الثاني الماضي ليطرح على
المعارضه السوريه مرجعيه سياسيه موحده
تحسم الكثير من نقاط الاختلاف والتردد
التي شكلت بنحو ما متنفسا للنظام السوري
بحجه يقارع بها خصومه ومع ميثاقه لقي
الاطار الجديد ترحيبا عربيا وغربيا
وامريكيا واسعا جعله بحسب مناصريه مؤهلا
اكثر من اي وقت مضى ل يتحدث باسم تطلعات
السوريين في الحريه والكرامه امام الهيئات
والمنتديات الدوليه ومنها اجتماع ما بات
يعرف ب اصدقاء سوريا المرتقب عقده في
الثاني عشر من الشهر الجاري في المغرب
خطوه يضعها القائمون عليها في مسار
استكمال البنيه السياسيه للائتلاف
جاء فيما يبدو استجابه لدعوات في الداخل
والخارج السوري لتوحيد صفوف المعارضه
وجمعها على مشروع موحد يرقى الى مستوى
الزخم الميداني الذي تعرفه البلاد على وقع
مواجهه مصيريه بين الجيشين ام والحر
المقاتلون يستولون على مزيد من القواعد
العسكريه التابعه للنظام ويقتربون يوما
بعد يوم من تطويق العاصمه دمشق تمهيدا
لاسقاط حكم الاسد بالضربه العسكريه
القاضيه ويقدمون لذلك بتشكيل قياده عسكريه
موحده للثوره ضمن مسار تصاعدي ينتظر من
كافه القوى المعارضه ان تجتمع على قلب رجل
واحد في مرحله من مخي سوريا الجديده لم
تعد تحتمل بحسب هم اي مظهر او مفعول سلبي
الانقسامات السياسيه
معنا في هذه الحلقه السيده فرح الاساس هي
ناشطه سوريا المعارضه رئيسه المركز العربي
الامريكي للابحاث من لندن الاعلاميه سوريا
المعارض سيد بسام شعاره
وعبر الهاتف من الحدود السوريه التركيه
المستشار السياسي للمجلس السوري الحر اه
بسام الداده ولكن قبل ان نبدا النقاش مع
ضيوفنا نتوقف من مقر مؤتمر الائتلاف في
القاهره مع عضو اللجنه القانونيه في
الائتلاف الوطني السوري وعضو المكتب
التنفيذي للمجلس السوري هشام مروه اهلا
بضيوفنا جميع سيد مروان ما هي طبيعه ال ال
اه الصعوبات التي تعترض المجتمعين الان في
القاهره بخصوص الخروج هيكل تنظيمي واضح
وبحكومه سوريا مؤقته ورئيس لها
اه اسمح لي اولا مساء الخير لضيوفك الكرام
والمشاهدين اه حاليا اه ما اريد تسليط
الاضواء على انه ليست هناك مشكله في مساله
اعداد هيكل تنظيمي نحن نناقش استكمال
الهيئات
وتشكيلات الائتلاف اه هذه ال ال الهيئات
وهذه التي التشكيلات المناقشه حولها يتم
عرض بعض الاثناء ال ال مرشحه لان تشغل هذه
ال اه المواقع المطلوبه اداريا ثلاثه هناك
صعوبات اداريه او صعوبات تقنيه انما هي
مشاورات وتسهيلات اه وضحوا
يكون صالحا
ان يكون في هذا المكان اه في هذا يعني
انجز اليوم اه على سبيل المثال ال اه
انتخاب رئيس رئيس المجلس هو الاستاذ جورج
الصبر الذي يشغل رئيس المجلس الوطني البحث
جاري في اعداد اه او استكمال اسماء الهيئه
السياسيه للائتلاف الوطني الائتلاف الوطني
لقوى الثوره والمعارضه التي ستشكل اه
القياده السياسيه لهذا اه الائتلاف تعمل
مع رئيس المجلس النوابي من اجل بلوره
سياسيه تقود ال المرحله السياسيه
اه ليست هناك صعوبات من هذا القبيل اه اما
اه
استكمال الاعمال الاداريه التنظيمات
الذريه قد انتهت في الدوحه الاسبوع الفائت
في القاهره ولكن يبدو ال ال الانظار تتجه
بشكل خاص لموضوع الحكومه السوريه المؤقته
اذا كانت هناك مشكله في الاسماء في الهيئه
الاداريه بالنسبه للحكومه ربما المشكله
ستكون اكثر تعقيدا يعني اسمح لي اشعر ان
المشكله في تحديد اثناء ال ال ورؤساء
الوزاره المنتظره ستكون ربما ايسر لانه
هنا نبحث عن عشره اسماء او
شخص واحد وسيبحث في بمعايير معينه على
الكفاءه عن القدره عن الشروط التي وضعها
النظام الاساسي للائتلاف من كون هذا الرجل
او هذه السيده الذين سيقومون ب تشكيل
الوزاره من الذين شاركوا بالثوره من الذين
اه تشهد الله يشهد لهم تاريخهم بالقدره
والكفاءه والنزاهه من الذين لم يتورطوا لم
يكون من اركان النظام اه الى يعني الى
جمله ال الاشتراطات التي انا ارى الى
تشكيل الوزاره المشكله عندنا في في موضوع
تشكيل الوزاره هو الظروف الدوليه توافقنا
في الدوحه وكان احد بنود الاتفاق الرئيسي
اتفاق الدوحه ان يتم تشكيل الحكومه
المؤقته بعد الحصول على الاعتراف الدولي
اعتقد الشيء لا يعطي الحكومه الشرعيه
الشرعيه التي تمتلكها الائتلاف من الداخل
ومن الخارج هي التي تمكنه من الانتاج
حكومه قويه الحكومه القويه هي المطلوبه
جماهيريه من الداخليه الخارجيه
حكومه غير قائلا تكون المتمتعه بالشرعيه
لم تمت على القوه المتمتعه بالقدره على
القيام بعملها ستوجد
على وجود البيئه الطبيعيه المناسبه بدايه
هذه الحكومه البحث لا يتحول ليس هناك
مشكله حول اه رئيس الوزاره او غيره هذا
امر اتوقع انه سيكون جزيره المشكله
الرئيسيه هل تحققت الظروف القانونيه
المشروعيه السياسيه الداخليه والخارجيه
ويؤكد انه لن يكون تسميه لرئيس الوزراء ما
لم يتم استشاره الداخل الداخل مهم جدا الت
اخذ هو المحل الذي
الحكومه
شكرا على هذه المشاركه اه وضعتنا في صوره
ما يجري في اجتماعات الخير شكرا لك من
القاهره ايضا نسال السيد فرح الاتاسي عن
اه اه الطريقه التي تتابع بها اه اه ما
يجري في القاهره لاسيما هذه الاشاره ل اه
الظروف الدوليه والى ضروره استشاره الداخل
في اي خطوه اه اه قريبه
الحقيقه انا اجد ان هناك اخطاء تتكرر
تماما كما حصل مع المجلس الوطني السوري
وربما كان متوقعا نحن لنا كمراقبين نراقب
عمل الائتلاف ونحاول قدر استطاعتنا ان
نكون هناك فعلا نعمل مشترك جماعي موحد من
اجل الدفع ب اه الثوره السوريه وهي تقطف
ثمار صبرها اه اه يبدو ان هناك انشغال
الزائد واه ربما تضييع وقت غير مبرر اه في
تفاصيل اه اداريه وتفاصيل اه اه تصنيف كما
قلنا هياكل سياسيه واه يعني سميها كما شئت
هناك واحد وستين شخصا حتى الان هم من
يمثلون اه جسد ال ال اه الائتلاف الحالي
بينما كان المجلس الوطني اكثر من ذلك
العدد بكثير اه فيفترض ان يكون تسيير
وتنظيم عمل انشاء هذه الهياكل السياسيه
وخاصه ان الوضع في الداخل السوري وضع في
للغايه وضع سيئ لا يحتاج الى حياه سياسيه
موضوع عدم وجود حين وغاز وكهرباء ليس
بحاجه الى حكومه مؤقته وليست بحاجه الى
اراده سياسيه هناك عمل طارئ يجب ان تعمل
عليه هي مجموعه يفترض انها تمثل الثوره
السوريه ولكن الملاحظ ان هناك الحقيقه
الدخول في تفاصيل اه السابق لاوانها
تفاصيل اه لا تغني ولا تسمن عن جوع
اه و اضاعه الوقت في العديد من ال يعني
الكلام اه في العديد من هذه الاجتماعات
الحقيقه التي حصلت والتي تكررت في المجلس
الوطني السوري وكان من المفترض ان يتم
تلافي هذه اه ال الدخول في تفاصيل اه اه
موضوع اه يعني التمثيل السياسي بعض القوى
التمثيل السياسي لبعض التيارات التمثيل
السياسي نفس مشاكل المجلس الوطني الحقيقه
انا اراها اليوم تكرر نفسها في بعض
اجتماعات الائتلاف ونتمنى ان يتجاوزها اه
اه هذا الجسد المصغر للمعارضه الوطنيه
السوريه لكي يركز على اولويات الثوره الان
اولويات الداخل السوري الان ونحن امام
استحقاقات جديده اهمها اصدقاء مراكز وام
وايضا ما يحاك على المجتمع الدولي من
اجتماع جنيف 2 ومن اه امور اخرى اه يتم
التنسيق لها الان في لقياده هذه المرحله
الانتقاليه
الاجتماع مركز هام جدا اه اجتماع يعقد في
الثاني عشر من من هذا الشهر
اه اه هل هل تتوقع ان يتم حسم هذه
الاشكالات ال القائمه في القاهره قبل هذا
الموعد المهم الذي يفترض ان يكون المناسبه
الحقيقيه اللي تسويق بين قوسين اه ال ال
المعارضه السوريه من جديد في هذا الهيكل
الجديد
دعني اقول يفترض ذلك بل اقول يجب ذلك يجب
تحقيق ذلك الغرب يتسرع منذ اليوم الاول
كلما اسقطنا ذريعه تبرز ذريعه اخرى بمعنى
اخر انا اقول بكل صراحه الغرب لا يملك
اراده او ليس عنده اراده او ليس عنده قرار
لدعم الشعب السوري في كل مره يبحثون عن
اعذار وحجج واهيه لكي يبرروا عجزهم وتقاسم
عن دعم الشعب السوري
توحدت المعارضه السياسيه وتوحدت المعارضه
العسكريه مطلوب يوم الاثنين القادم غدا من
رئيس الائتلاف ان يلتقي وزراء خارجيه سبعه
وعشرين دوله اوروبيه
وان يقدم لهم خريطه الطريق المرحله
القادمه في كل يوم يبحثون عن سبب لتاخير
او لتبرير عجزهم او عدم دعمهم للشعب
السوري الوضع الان خطير النظام بالناس
الطائرات تقصد المدافع تقصف والشعب السوري
يحتاج الى رصاصه يحتاج الى رغيف خبز اليوم
نقطه الى اربعمائه ليره لا توجد جهه
سياسيه تتولى هذا الشان هناك ائتلاف ولكن
هذا الائتلاف بكل اسف مشغول باستكمال
هياكلها الاداريه والقانونيه والسياسيه
والمطلوب الان ليس فقط من اجل الخارج بل
من اجل الداخل ان يتفرغوا الشان الداخلي ل
اوضاع اللاجئين لتامين مستلزمات الجيش
الحر الجيش الحر منذ اشهر لم يتلقى اي دعم
عسكري انا اقول هذا بوضوح ولذلك اقول
اليوم بغض النظر انا لست موضوع في
الائتلاف ولكن ما عندي ملاحظات على
الائتلاف وعلى المجلس العسكري ولكن انا مع
الائتلاف ومع القياده الموحده ويفترض الان
ان شده الازمه لكي نواجه العالم لكي نتمكن
ايضا من مواجهه بشار الاسد
اسمح لي اسمح لي فقط انه في الوقت الذي
يقع النقاش فيه حول هذه المسائل المتعلقه
ب اه اه اه ال الهيكل الاداري والسياسي
الجديد على الصعيد العسكري وهنا اسال
السيد اه بسام الداده المستشار السياسي
للجيش السوري الحر عن اه تقديره ل اه خطوه
توحيد ال الهيئه العسكريه وما يمكن ان
تعطيه مندفعه للسياسيين حتى يسيروا على
نفس المنوال
حقيقه كان عمل
الزوار على الارض عندما ارسلوا وفود لهم
الى منطقه معينه وتم خلالها انشاء امكانيه
عسكريه جديده
اه متخصصه وفي سياده العميد سليم ادريس
وكانت حقيقه انجاز حقيقي واعتقد انهم
سبقوا تماما الائتلاف والمعارضه السياسيه
وعلى غروب من توسع هم وعلى الرغم من تشرذم
وعلى الرغم من تبعدهم الا انه من تقوم
قرروا بان هذا الوقت هو وقت ال اه التقدم
وليس الى التقهقر وليس الى الرجوع الى
الوراء النظام نقاطه الشراكه فالمعارضه
العسكريه توحدا باذن الله وتم هناك انشاء
القياده المرحله العسكريه وب هيكليه يعني
اعتقد هيكليه مختلفه تماما حيث تم انشاء
اه رئيس اركان ومن ثم اه اه مساعدين رئاسه
اركان من الضباط المنشقين ومساعدين
النواب رئيس اركان من الاسوار المدنيين
وكذلك انشات بعض الادارات لمتابعه هذا
الامر فالمعارضه العسكريه انجزت خلال
الايام الماضيه يعني انجاز اه اعتقد بانه
انشاء الله سيكون الامر الحاكم في مصر على
هذا النظام وسيكون هذا تاشيره كبير جدا
على ما بعد سقوط النظام حتى تكون الامور
منضبطه باذن الله ولم يقدم الذرائع الى
العالم وبات العالم الان ان يتقدم الى هذه
الثوره اليتيمه وان يدعمها اه فيما يتعلق
ب اه اه اه الضغط العسكريين على السياسيين
الخروج بنتائج ما الذي يمكن ان ننتظره
يعني اعتقد بان المعارضه السياسيه
المطالبه بكثير من الامور فهي متفرقه
تماما يعني على المعارضه العسكريه التي
تقاتل على جميع شبهات يعني الشماليه
عسكريه وانما الانسانيه والاغاثه
فالمعارضه السياسيه المطلوب منها كثير
وكما اوضحت
لا تاتي حقيقه يعني تماما فهي منتهيه في
امور الجانبيه وفي نقاشات الجانبيه فقط
فيها المجلس الوطني ونتمنى ان لا يقع فيها
الائتلاف على الائتلاف ان يكون فعلا جاده
بكل معنى الكلمه
يعتبر من الارض يجب الانتماء هي مسؤوليته
في ال في في رقبته من الدماء على ان يكون
اشد صرامه في التعامل في هذه الامور في
مدينه وان يكون دقيقين و يخرج بنتائج
حقيقيه ونحن طالبنا هم وقدمه وثيقه مبادئ
عشره بالنسبه للائتلاف اه يعني
جزء من هذه الوثيقه المبادره التي اعلنها
المجلس العسكري نعم نحن السور المجتمعون
اه في كافه المحافظات السوريه من قاده
الكتاب السوريه ورؤساء المجالس السوريه
والعسكريه والمستقلين وبعد ان قررنا توحيد
الصفوف هيئه اركان عاما وسط القتال حتى
اسقاط النظام بكافه رموزه وكاله يعلن عن
وثيقه مبادئ عامه وسياسيه لاهداف ثورتنا
اولا العمل على اسقاط النظام بكافه اشكاله
وتقديمه للمحاكمه ورفض اي حوار او تفاوض
معه
مع اهميه الوثيقه الذي اه الذي اه التي
تفضلت به ذكر مقتطفات منها يبقى ال الجانب
المهم هو اه كيف تستطيع الطبقه السياسيه
السوريه المعارضه وهذا ما سنتطرق اليه بعد
الفاصل كيف تستطيع الطبقه السياسيه
المعارضه ان تواكب هذا التقدم العسكري اه
القائم على الارض في سوريا حتى تخرج الى
الراي العام الدولي والى المجتمع الدولي
بصيغه اكثر اقناعا عبر الائتلاف اكثر
قناعه مما كانت عليه في السابق في تجربه
المجلس الوطني نعود اليكم بعد هذا الفاصل
نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الاجتماعات
الجاريه حاليا في القاهره ل اه الائتلاف
الوطني لقوى الثوره والمعارضه السوريه
اه سيده ال الاساسي اه رغم التحفظات التي
تبديها قبل قليل فيما يتعلق ب اه سير
النقاشات في القاهره هل تعتقدين مع ذلك
بان اه للخروج بحد ادنى من النتائج سيعطى
دفعه اه اه مكانه المعارضه السوريه في
الخارج لا سيما مع اجتماعات مراكش وهذه
الاتصالات مع الجانب الاوروبي
اه اكيد هم بحاجه تماما يعني يتم هذا
التوافق الكامل بين كافه الاطراف المختلفه
التي تشكل هذا الائتلاف نحن لا يجب ان لا
ننسى ان هذا الائتلاف عباره عن تكتلات
سياسيه موجوده داخل هذا الجسد الائتلاف
لكن الحقيقه ان مصدر قوه الائتلاف فعلا اه
هو اليوم هذا الاستحقاق الكره هي الان
بالملعب الدولي لنرى فعلا جديه اه هذا
المجتمع الدولي في التعامل مع المعارضه
السياسيه قوه الائتلاف كشفت سياسي جديد
اولا ان يستمد شرعيته من الداخل وموافقه
اه عدد كبير من القوى الثوريه والحراك
الفاعل والكتائب وقوى المقاومه الوطنيه
السوريه مع هذا الجسد السياسي الجديد
ثانيا فعلا ان يقوم هذا المجتمع الدولي
بالاعتراف الكامل بهذا الجسد السياسي
بمعنى اسقاط شرعيه النظام فعليا وليس
اسميا ما معنى ان يقوم المجتمع الدولي
بتعيين مندوبين بين قوسين او ممثلين بين
قوسين لقوى الائتلاف في بعض عواصم القرار
بينما لا تزال اه اه سفراء النظام موجودين
في هذا في عواصم هذه
القوى الغربيه المطلوب تسليم السفارات
المطلوب ان يقوم السفراء اه الائتلاف
الوطني السوري لمتابعه احوال السوريين في
الدول الغربيه واخص هنا في دول الخليج
العربي اه المطلوبه اولا اخيرا هو رفض رفض
الداخل السوري بكل ما يحتاجه اولا اسيا
لان فعلا اليوم هناك ازمه انسانيه اه اه
تمر في سوريا يعني نحن نستعجل تماما من
انشغال هذا المجتمع الدولي في اتفاقات
جنيف
وبالعوده الى اه اه اه مجلس الامن ال
البحث في العوده الى مجلس الامن وهناك
ازمه انسانيه يمر بها الشعب السوري اه
ازمه فضيعه نحن نخسر اه يوميا ما يقل عن
مائه شهيد البرامج الاسلحه الكيماويه التى
تم استخدامها فى داريا في القصف على داريا
هناك امور يجب ان ينظر فيها الان هذه هي
اولويات الثوره الان فاذا فعلا تم
الاعتراف الكامل والشرعي بهذا الائتلاف
ممثلا وحيدا ورثته بالدعم السياسي الحقيقي
والدعم المالي لان ال اه ما بحاجه ل هو
الائتلاف ما فشلت في تحقيقه المجلس الوطني
وهو ما اسست تاسيس ومؤسسه العمل المعارض
التفرغ للثوره لان يكون هناك اشخاص في كل
موزعين على قارات العالم الخمسه ويلتقون
مره في الشهر وهي تقوم مره في الاسبوع يجب
ان تقول هناك قياده سياسيه لمتابعه الوضع
الميداني والتنسيق الان مع القياده
العسكريه في غرفه مغلقه توجد فيها الشاشات
يقوم باستعراض الوضع الميداني يوميا لا
يعني ياتون ويجتمعون اه مره في الشهر هنا
وهناك هذا لن يساعد على مواكبه كما قلت
الاحداث المتسارعه في الداخل السوري
واليوم الثوار بصمودهم وبسالتهم وشجاعتهم
يقطعون اوصال النظام السوري يجب ان نوصف
الحاله في الداخل السوري اليوم النظام
السوري المحاصر النظام السوري مقطع
الاوصال النظام السوري منها
الاطراف للاخرين الصادر يعني هذا الاعتراف
ال ال ال ال الدولي الكامل كما اه تطمئن
اه اه في ذلك اه اه هل هل هو اه خطوه ممكن
السيد بسام جعاره لانه اشارت قبل قليل الى
موضوع السفراء مثلا سيد منذر ماخوس هو
تقريبا ال ال السفير ال الوحيد في عاصمه
اه اه غربيه في فرنسا تحديدا الذي يمثل اه
ال الهيئه هيئه المعارضه وليس النظام في
سوريا
يعني هو ليس السفير هو مثل الائتلاف وهذا
امر خاطئ كل ما نخشاه الان ان تكون هناك
السفارتين في كل
المنطقه وهذا يعني ان سوريا ستقسم ما
اخشاه الان ليس من الائتلاف ولا من اي جهه
اخرى هناك اجنده واضحه الغرب والشرق
اتفقا على انجاز تسويه والتسويه سوف تتم
كما يرون هم على حساب الشعب السوري هم
وضعوا كل ما يمكن وضعه لانجاز هذا التسويه
ولكنهم اسقطوا من حسابهم الشعب السوري هم
لم يعني لم يظهروا هذا الشعب في حساباتهم
انا اقول لك بكل وضوح هناك تسويه سوف
تنتهي او كما يريدون تحت شعار لا غالب ولا
مغلوب اي اعاده انتاج النظام بشكل الطف
هذا الامر لن يكون سواء من خلال الائتلاف
او خلال القياده العسكريه لا سمح الله او
من خلال اي قوه اخرى في العالم نحن نعرف
تماما ما الذي يضم الان في المطابخ
الدوليه هناك اجتماعات روسيه ايرانيه
امريكيه اوروبيه وقال وها لنا صراحه قالوا
لا مفر من التسويه زمن التسويات انتهى
الشعب السوري اسقط كل شيء ايضا اريد ان
اقول امر اهم الاهم الان هو منع استخدام
الكيماوي عندنا معلومات مؤكده بان هناك
طائرتان عسكريتان في مطار الضير ومطالب
لاي فريق دمشق
محملتان بالصواريخ وجاهزه بانتظار الاوامر
على العالم ان يتصرف قبل ان يقدم النظام
على ارتكاب مجزره كبرى الشعب السوري انا
اؤكد لك سوف يختص من جميع المجرمين واذا
غامر بالشهر واطلق الكيماوي فان حسابه
وحساب زمرته سيكون شديدا انا اؤكد الان
النظام على بعد خطوات من استخدام الكيماوي
وعلى العالم الان هل يتحرك ويجتمعون
وفي العواصم الاوروبيه ولكن الاهم الان هو
منع الشر قبل وقوعه وانا اؤكد لك بانه
تفصلنا الكيماوي ايام قليله فقط شكرا
جزيلا لك السيد بسام جعاره الاعلام السوري
المعارضه كنت معنا من لندن شكرا جزيلا
ايضا للسيده فرح الاتاسي الناشطه السوريه
المعارضه رئيسه المركز العربي الامريكي
للابحاث نشكر ايضا سيد بسام الداده
المستشار السياسي للجيش السوري الحر اه اه
كان معنا عبر الهاتف من الحدود السوريه
التركيه
وكان ايضا معنا في بدايه هذه الحلقه السيد
هشام روائع عضو المكتب التنفيذي للمجلس
السوري وضعنا في صوره ما يجري اه في
اجتماعات القاهره حاليا بهذا نصل الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
اللقاء